[Music]
foreign
basically
um
oh
we
there we go
just for today
but i'll stand there
there you go
i think that's max
um
all right
oh
thank you
thank you
um
no i needed it
red dress red dress red dress song
you know that dance song song about
someone in a red dress
anyone know what the devil was dead oh
god i didn't know that part
sorry okay uh good afternoon everybody
i'm joined by our great whip senator
richard
j durbin now we just finished a very
good
virtual discussion in our caucus and the
senate is working
boldly and quickly to respond to the
covet crisis
deliver help to americans who need it
the most everywhere we go in our states
people are saying get the bill passed
a majority of republican citizens are
for the bill
the only people who don't seem to be for
the bill are republican senators here
in washington but we are on track
to get this bill done and get it on the
president's desk
before the expiration of the enhanced
unemployment benefits which is march
14th
we're going to meet that deadline and
it's going to be a robust strong bill
just as we asked for
not exactly the same but very close to
the bill that president biden proposed
we're also moving quickly to hold
confirmation hearings on the floor
uh president biden with president
biden's highly qualified and experienced
cab
cabinet nominees linda thomas greenfield
and tom
vilsack will be confirmed today jennifer
grant home by the end of the week miguel
cardona and gina ramondo early next week
so we're making good progress in filling
that cabinet
the bottom line is simple when i became
leader people said you've got so much to
do
i said we can get all three things done
president's cabinet
covert relief impeachment trial and as
you've seen
we're making we've we're in the process
of getting all of those done
one thing is clear in this new senate
the era of mitch mcconnell's legislative
graveyard
is over while the republicans use their
time in the majority to deliver tax cuts
to the rich
and take away health care from millions
of americans
the senate democratic majority is
delivering help to americans just what
americans want
there is sorry there is tremendous
tremendous
energy in our democratic caucus to pass
laws that will help
our country and help our people and
restore
the um face in government people had
poor mitch mcconnell started uh
using it as a legislative graveyard and
so many other republicans tried to block
things that helped people
so today on our caucus call i directed
the chairs and members of our relevant
committees
to start drafting a legislative package
to outcompete china
and create new american jobs
the legislation will have as its
centerpiece a bipartisan bill
bicameral bipartisan bill the endless
frontiers act
which i introduced last year with todd
young
and representatives ro khanna and mike
gallagher in the house
and it will take the key cutting
industries
and make american investments so we will
out compete china in all of them
in addition we will make serious
investments and strengthen in the u.s
semiconductor industry to outcompete
china
and stop depending on foreign sources
right now
semiconductor manufacturing is a
dangerous weak spot in our economy
and and in our national security that
has to change
you've all seen that auto plants
throughout america are closed because
they can't get the tips
we cannot rely on foreign processors for
the chips
we cannot let china get ahead of us in
ship production
this will be part of the proposal that
we will introduce
we will also talk about the build out of
5g and how america can remain number one
there
and all of these have bipartisan support
the bill we will intend to introduce and
i talked to senator young about it
he's eager to get it done we'll be
bipartisan
our intention is to put this legislation
on the senate floor for a vote this
spring
to get a little more specific the new
legislation must achieve three
three goals enhance american
competitiveness with china
by investing in american innovation
american workers amen
american manufacturing invest in
strategic partners and alliances nato
southeast asian india
and expose curb and end once and for all
china's predatory practices which have
hurt
so many american jobs we're looking at
emergency
funding to implement the bipartisan
semiconductor program as part of this
package
you all know about the chip shortage i
want this bill to address america's
short-term
and long-term plan does protect
protect the semiconductor supply chain
and to keep us number one in things like
ai 5g quantum computing
biomedical research storage
all of these things are part of the bill
and the endless frontiers act so we need
to get a bill like this to the
president's desk quickly
to protect america's long-term economic
and national security
senator durbin
my thanks to leader charles ellis
schumer
who is remember what his name was i gave
him a name a few weeks ago anyone
remember
come on you get first question
you get first question if you remember
this is a contest this is a serious news
conference
yeah first question
goes to mr punchbowl
by the way nah forget it
i'm going to give you my name and you
remember it mine's harder
charles is usually higher but it's not
high kaya
isaiah next week first question
go ahead i know why we can but i can't
remember
last night president biden paid a
tribute to the five hundred thousand
that we have lost and their families
as an acknowledgement of the pain and
loss that america has sustained
this president is not running away from
reality
he is facing it and he's asking congress
to join him in uniting
and healing our nation last year
almost 12 months ago exactly 96 senators
democrats and republicans and a
bipartisan show of support passed the
cares act
a more than two trillion dollar rescue
plan the largest spending bill ever
enacted by congress
then in december when the measure came
up for another 900 billion dollars that
was needed
92 senators voted a strong bipartisan
vote
can we expect anything less when
president biden brings us
the american rescue plan this rescue
program
is designed to put vaccine on the
streets
in the clinics and in the arms of
americans as quickly as possible
it has fourteen hundred dollars more in
cash payments
promised to families across the united
states there is money in this as well
to deal with the deadline that we face
in terms of unemployment benefits
on march 14th help for those who are
renting and can't afford to pay
emergency provisions across the board
for schools
individuals families businesses
and it needs to be passed quickly i
joined senator schumer
in asking the republicans to put aside
politics
and to stand with joe biden and with the
american people
now the second point i would like to
make is we concluded
the hearing on merrick garland the
nominee to be attorney general of the
united states today
there was a good happy ending to that
wasn't anticipated
senator tom tillis the republican of
north carolina
didn't make our hearing yesterday in
person but he wanted to come in today
to say a positive thing about merrick
garland and to announce that he was
voting for him
there's another republican senator who's
told me the same i think
it is a growing trend his presentation
before the committee was as powerful as
any nominee i've ever seen
he answered every question and he did it
with class
and with professionalism and obviously
with an understanding of the law
we need him now in the department of
justice i hope that we can find a way to
move him quickly
he is the last person in the team when
it comes to national security
who should be in place we've taken care
of the department of defense
taking care of the director of national
intelligence department of homeland
security
let's put an attorney general on the job
as quickly as possible
i think we'll be able to report him on
monday from the judiciary committee
and i hope senator schumer is successful
in bringing this to the floor as quickly
as possible
thank you just one other point that
senator durbin reminded me
covet crisis rages a republican
president
democrats come together with republicans
and pass
two bills or four bills really republic
democratic president
republicans don't even work with
democrats if anyone doubts who's more
interested in bipartisanship just look
at that
fresno han go ahead
the first step is to go before
reconciliation
before the parliamentarian that will
occur on wednesday bernie sanders and i
are
arguing very strongly for 15
and for it to be reconcilable we're
going to await her judgment
uh before we go any further
next question yes um thank you mr leader
um
if you can tell us anything more about
march 4th there's shadow that there
could be another potential plan
something like
what we saw on january 6 and is the
security apparatus here
ready for something well the security
apparatus is a lot better
than it was on january 6. the you can
just walk around and see
all the national guardsmen and women i
see a whole lot of them from new york
um so that's much better obviously
there's more protection around the
capitol
and obviously the police forces are more
alert
uh but you can always do better and
that's why we're having the hearing
today and that's why we're doing a
thorough investigation as to what went
wrong
and then try to make sure it's improved
with
uh improved so it never ever happens
again
well look i was proud to co-sponsor the
comprehensive immigration bill along
with senator durbin senator
menendez um i'd like to see a pathway
for citizenship to 11 million i'd like
to see the america be more friendly to
immigrants
who are needed for both family
reunification and jobs
so my my preference is to pass
a comprehensive bill but if um
it is determined that the best way to go
forward is to
go forward in pieces and the house is
thinking of doing that
it's something i'd certainly look at i
want to get as much done as possible
yes
what exactly are you doing and where are
you finding these well i'm not going to
get into specifics and names but we're
continuing to look i think mira tandon
would be an outstanding omb uh nominee
and for republicans who looked the other
way with the nastiest of treats by their
president their leader for now to
say near attend and shouldn't get in
because of her tweets is a little bit of
a contradiction
chairman sanders says there's already
discussion about a potential second
reconciliation package for a jobs bill
that was reported by the washington post
this to be as large as three trillion
what do you think should be in that
second package and what do you think the
title okay well i'm not go
look i think we need to go further than
just
the american rescue plan which deals
with rescue which deals with the
immediate problems
but we need a strong stimulus to get our
long-term
economy going if you read today's
washington post
uh unemployed real unemployment is still
10
and one of the leading economists i
can't remember if it was power someone
said unemployment is going to stay with
us a very long time
so we need a strong stimulus that
creates and builds jobs and pumps up the
economy
for a long period of time and so i the
buildback better plan is something that
i think we would turn to very soon
after the um american rescue plan is
done
it should be it should have big
infrastructure it should be green
it should include communities that are
left out it should deal with worker
training
the purpose is to get the economy going
at a fast clip once and for all so we
can have the growth that we had in the
70s and 80s not the growth we've had
since uh 2000 which has been very low
yes
first things first we're fighting hard
to get it done
we're fighting hard to get it done
that's what we're fighting for now
on today's first open hearing on the
january 6 attack and what do you want to
hear tomorrow from the
acting capital police keep an acting
sergeant at arms and what do you want to
see
look we want to see what went wrong and
what we can do to make it better
you know it's very good i think senators
uh peters and klobuchar have had a very
good hearing very comprehensive lots of
questions were asked
and we need to know what went wrong to
make sure we know what we'll do what
will happen
what we can do to make sure it never
happens again yes
curious if uh if you have heard
republicans uh have apparently offered
or have they made this offer about
splitting and even split to this
january 6th commission and you have any
look we need a commission that's going
to get to the bottom of this and uh
i'm i've been talking to leader speaker
pelosi about it but
i'm not going to get into details of
what we've talked about
i think we needed to get to the bottom
of what happened
with and it should be fearless senator
if you could just talk about the role
that senator manchin is playing in your
caucus right now obviously with the 15
minimum wage and you're attaining
i've made a pitch today to our entire
caucus
and i said that we need to pass this
bill
the american people the american public
demands it and everyone
is going to have things that they want
to see in the bill and we'll work hard
to see if we can get those things in the
bill
but job number one is to pass the bill
pass the bill we must and i have
confidence we will do it
last any one senator can have in a 50-50
split
what are you doing to make sure that
everybody stays united on upcoming
nominations and reconciliation
this is my answer i speak to my members
all the time and i have a leadership
team that meets monday night
on that leadership team are bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren
of course dick durbin and joe manchin
and
mark warner and we discuss it out and so
far so far we've had great unity
on impeachment we had great unity on the
two bills that have come before the two
votes that have come before us on
reconciliation
we've had great unity so we've had a lot
of unity and
we need to keep it with 50 votes we need
our unity and we're fighting to get it
and so far so good thank you everybody
for those who are unfamiliar that was a
flip phone
senator
so do you think that both would be able
to pass the senator or which one are you
prioritizing
well let me tell you we're watching
first for the house action
we think the dream and promise act will
pass we hope
as well as a farm labor uh bill will
pass
and be sent to us which would certainly
be a good starting place
i think for immigration what i'm doing
is
reaching out not only on my side of the
aisle but to individual republican
senators
some of whom would surprise you i'd gone
to him and i said i've never brought up
immigration with you before
can we talk no i said sure let's let's
see what we can agree on
so there is a more open-minded approach
than i expected
on the republican side that doesn't mean
we've got 60 votes lined up
i've got to reach the point we do and i
agree with senator schumer
i want it all i want a comprehensive
bill but if we can't get
all of it i want to get as many
important elements together in a bill
that can pass
with 60 votes supporting it on the floor
okay can we ask you on the minimum wage
i talk to joe all the time i'm part of
the group i managed to sneak in the door
the group of 18 senators nine democrats
and nine republicans
and i've worked with them for months and
it's a wonderful
group joe has
won the respect of many of the people in
the group as well as in his own caucus
but he's an independent mind person and
i can sit down and talk to him i can't
always bring him to agreement
but he always he's always wanting to sit
down and explain his point of view and
be open to new thoughts
that's the most any whip could ask and
remember okay seemed to indicate that
when he told his caucus at lunch
was the doctor class was still seeming
sitting like it's a message to manson
that he has to get on board
is that how you it was a message to it
was a message to the whole caucus
when you get into this bill and see all
the provisions and sections in it
i want to make some calls down to
schumer's staff there are two or three
things
that are important to me and two or
three things that may be under attack
here in the senate so i'm sure that's
going on and he's begging all of us
despite any differences with any one
section of the bill that we hang
together
this is the signature provision of the
biden administration in terms of dealing
with the pandemic
and the economy and we need to stick
together that's it
i was like we're doing the story
tomorrow security might as well get
about it